this week's videos are sponsored by
expressvpn more on them after the reaction
people Purge you can't be drinking while I go
to purge I really can't take two Purge this is
the reject Nation it is time for Purge three
we are Betty and Veronica we are who are the
other people I compar to and Louise yeah we are
T Roy Batman and Robin which one's Batman we will
be your Purge mommies for the day your Purge
sisters but we can't take the place of purge
Daddy no nobody can we know who Purge daddy is
so hot Frank is there going this there better be
that's not really how this franchise works yeah
probably not a little sad when I think about it
unless he's running for president I don't know
what this is but it is election year sounds like
it will be really peaceful as all election years
are with no uh disapproving looks or different
opinions at all oh that's not true I hope it's
as much fun as the first two though if you guys
do too like this video comment subscribe yes and
ring the bell ring the bell that was a purge at
the end that had some Gusto yeah purging it
you really wanted them to ring the bell and
I want you guys to be as sexy as possible and
what that means is that you have to go over to
patreon become a super sexy reject over there
where you can link up with your own copy Greg
and John cover several shows exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs included
that's for the sexy people only super sexy what
are we purging this time what are we getting rid
of what oh right what are we actually getting
rid of um okay good yes and fear we're purging
fear today fear have no fear it's election
year yeah baby that was good she brought it
back doing it Purge Purge we're doing
it okay do I push you harder every time
she's getting aggressive listen
she's a fortress I am not yes I
am a fortress I'm a fortress that's
a whole foot shorter than you hi bir
mommy bum it's funny cuz we have no
mommies we don't we're both momless
so we'll be your Birch mom me and Roxy
will be will be fillings for you guys
who also don't have moms in the market
for a purge mommy we've got we right
here okay Tunes to start setting
a Vibe I'm loving it I'm excited
it makes me feel like we're in a different decade
are they having what are we hearing ooh
T-Rex that's one of my nicknames really
yeah [Music] any going oh snap okay we in it
had my Purge playlist I put a lot of thought
into it okay Joker and then I thought George
Clinton the king of interplanetary funmor is
psychedelic Rock would leave you feeling funky
George Clinton is funky now they've played a lot
of per games tonight are those googly eyes on
his cheeks yeah it's called mommy's Choice momy
which one of you will survive this year's
Purge oh it's like borrowing from Sophie's
Choice okay so he's the most Sinister villain
that we've seen like straight up so far right
yeah and like immediately 18 years later what
two days before the annual what year are we in
this is just one of a dozen protests around our
Capital after reports emerged claiming that the
new founding fathers had been using the purge
to help their own economic agenda this we by
incendiary Purge detractor Dante Bishop for the
past 20 years God there he is less welfare less
health care less housing a Monumental effect
on the upcoming presidential election Ed Owens
has been losing ground to wildcard independent
candidate Senator Charlie ran oh yet from Lost
Ron was forced to watch the brutal execution
of her entire family on Purge Night with one
goal in mind to put an end to the annual holiday
the greatest threat to the nffa regime so there's
literally a purge Mommy now yeah she's it would
she be our mommy please if we ask nicely we have
our people out there countering all this anti-
nffa [__] feels really not like BS all these
idealistic pigs they want the impossible everyone
to have it's not impossible not even close some
cannot have not enough to go around it's so
not true there are billions and billions to
go around trillion so much we are going to use
this year's Purge to do some spring cleaning
gentlemen there are people who really talk like
that my God and it's so scary I'm like dude if
you just sold your yacht you could take care of
like 30,000 people one of their five Yachts yeah
just sell one of the Yachts just one where
our great nffa leaders gather together and
Slaughter Innocents is murder our new religion
murder is our new religion that's Snappy the
midnight Purge Mass where NFA leaders gather
to celebrate he looks like Mitt Romney sorry
yeah oh God who this who the oh good looking
good looking there you don't recognize Frank
yeah it is time to call upon the better angels of
our nature get it Purge Mama secure the audience
on I'd like to talk to you guys what is he from
Chief that's bugging me she's no good to anyone
dead which one this the the the big the handsome
guy yeah like from the from other from the other
thing that I just watched though Rock The Purge
he's from The Purge you're making a joke I know
I'm like he's was just in a recent movie The Purge
babe the one we just saw no The Purge too no he's
in that too that's perch daddy bab that's Frank
gillo no what wait what am I going crazy are you
having a stroke oh my God she can do it all that
useless [__] can't butter a damn Bagel correctly
I go butter your bagel boss he is um what is
his name what is his name he's very famous you
just be careful kid with all that hope because it
can be a bad thing hope can lead to a lot of let
down yeah hope is not good to have I carry none
of it my heart was Obama's full slogan hope can
change the world March 20th here we go Pisces
season get those blue flowers get them rocking
the rules protecting level 10 government officials
have been revoked NFA is revoking The Purge rule
that protects government officials is ranking
10 on Purge night if the voters get wind that
I'm hiding in a fortress like some rich [__]
I lose votes and the nffa wins I stay home like
99% of the population that's right Purge Mommy
get it it's like when people in office don't
put their kids in public school and it's just like
do you not even believe in your own school system
like that's true if you don't believe in your own
government you can't rule okay that legitimately
scared me I also know her from something she's
a fortress y'all she does not get scared come on
inside The Purge is Halloween for adults
h no oh God where's the candy this guy's
nuts we here to experience the purge to kill
release all the anger and hate murder tourism
it's the new booming business in our country
this year shouldn't you just like close the
borders during The Purge be like you can't come
in here next time you need something just give
us a call I'll have Marcos run it open and save
you the trip okay I come by to flirt with you
Joe me you better get out these girls going
to steal oh hey girl hey okay okay what are
these girls doing oh they're being rude yeah
I don't like it all right girls give it up I
won't have to call the police give up to candy
or I'll have to take it away from you you touch
me and I scream damn dude give it back who are
you [__] I feel like she's the real purge Mama
now Lany Rucker OG Queen badass they called
you B W you're my mother hero now give back
whatever you stole okay I'm changing Purge Mama
to her sorry mister I was just playing you look
all whitish now wish I met you back in the day
a lot of ecus yeah yeah like we're like all up
in there we are I kind of like it it keeps me
like super invested I'm revamping the entire
thing we got new barricades on all the doors
all the windows back and front looks safe Chief
if you tell me it's safe once one more time I'm
going to throw you down the steps please don't do
that that was the funniest line of the whole
series and on everything B why are you raising
my rates now do you today do you know what today
is yeah I'm talking to you let me speak to your
super your super you should not be allowed to
raise people's [__] damn insurance company
they just raised a premium on my Purge coveries
just in general but thousands holy I have no Purge
coverage for this store holy [__] oh my god dude
this is terrible take over the government I just
have to protect this place myself no how are you
feeling about these Graphics this time they're not
the same they're kind of the same right from the
last one I don't know do we get again I thought
that the guy that I was seeing earlier today is
not the same guy from the past M I think when
you see him out in these streets you're going
to know I'm to remember I started to think I I
was like he's not The Walking Dead guy that I was
thinking about andw Lincoln no you ready yeah yeah
okay let's go oh I love her they get some really
good actors in This franchise I will say I like
this wouldn't work if they were crap no this
is your emergency broadcast system announcing
the commencement of the annual Purge fire and
Emergency Medical Services will be unavailable
until tomorrow morning I wonder who they're going
to help no one has been granted special immunity
from The Purge no citizen or group will be exempt
oh so I said about the government right y all got
to come in nobody's exempt bro wow get ready and
we already know the security gates they're [Music]
breakable I like have Goosebumps I don't know
some music and the establishing shots but I feel
like ready Eric thank you for being here tonight
my pleasure Leo have a drink with me you don't
have a choice what purge mommy says Purge Mommy
gets I want them to hook up immediately they're
gonna they're gonna I've wanted them to hook up
with everybody I know right now we'll we might
get to see bir daddy sherz like I asked want
me to apply for this position I lost my son
some years ago I almost did something on Purge
night that would have destroyed a lot of lives
I Want This Night gone you remembering all that
now it's all back despite all that you you have
a big problem with how I do things you take risks
Senator my job is to eliminate risks and keep you
alive she is putting her people at risk the
only way that I can win is to risk everything
and that includes my life I respect it she's a
woman and she means business and she's hot but
that's not the point I hope Purge mommy takes
off her shirt too you said it but we were all
thinking [Laughter] it they probably won't
bother us okay no thank you that one was a
little nerve-wracking for me okay good maybe
she's not a full Fortress oh that was wild
why are they like risking their lives I mean
they're doing a good thing but I'm also like
ah whoa we brought a guillotine whoa that is a
wild shot is that kid wearing an alien that was
intense oh no no oh that's rough like are there
just this many people that are psychotic in this
country I guess so I thought I was going to
say [Laughter] p pu oh please stop please
help him and how are going down going to
decipher if it's like good or bad could be a
setup but you got this guy's like one of the
best snipers ever yeah for sure I feel it oh
it's Purge Night you don't sneak up on black
people good night blue cheese good night blue
cheese what is that I don't even know but
that's hilarious what the is good night
blue cheese chees good night blue jeez it's
got to be improv right yeah I guess so I'll
stay I want you to go home and be safe
I don't want you out here on Purge night
son oh no is he here to set him up no I hope no
that would break my heart is this car glowing
okay all right I should do that wild looking
for Christmas like how cool does that look
can't be safe but for Christmas it's okay
in the USA I don't think this is what Miley
meant oh my goodness kiss me no thanks
imagine deciding to do this it is like
adult Halloween with the costumes right now
right and a bedazzled gun what is happening
mostly just so they can open the doors with
all those lights on it they did some good
engineering okay let's see your face oh
the girl the sh it you Snickers stealer
what's he going to do shoot her ooh
there's your warning shot and I want
my candy bar and I'm going to take
it you don't got the balls to stop
me nice shot that was from the kid now go I
already took care of my mom and dad tonight
what oh dang uh y'all should kill her just put her
out of her misery what's up with that every day
in was like The Purge I know how to shot bus yeah
you do said well what's up with that I thought you
were just blue cheese but man you can snipe yeah
because if you missed she was dead good time for
brusi always a good time I don't know it's that
time it's that time he knew Purge Fortress good
one so good great timing when the old guy came
in just that was scary feel like you're agist bro
gosh all the stories in these movies combine
I'm interested how Purge Daddy and Juliet from
lost story is going to combine with yeah
the guy with the store store yeah yeah
what are you still doing up here you're
on first floor Duty how was the chck some
lightning go there's a mole Chief find a
bedroom I got it from here all right Leo
feel like it's that guy the old guy the bald
the balding guy you just if it is him you're
right for sure that was her mom who saved her
right and that was her as a kid yeah yeah you're
right got to be yes yeah okay well her Purge
mommy saved her yeah so now you it's your turn
to be a mommy with Purge daddy don't you take
a break go watch some TV huh it's going to be a
long night please sir I'm skeptical of the guy
who just cleared um that guy I'm skeptical of
them okay is Leo watching or no oh my goodness
okay SWAT coming for you honey white power wow
oh God okay so tell me how you feel yeah what
do you guys stand for what do you guys think
about mostly imagine getting that embroidered
on something like you send it out for embroider
yeah who's everyone's like H wait is he opening
the oh you might have been right about him knew
it okay you knew it what's going on with Pur
D that text message like all set or whatever
yeah I think he has it on Loop he must have it on
Loop or something yeah fudge must have mess with
it nothing going on Purge daddy you ready for
this you better get ready you want smoke no you
better you don't want that Purge daddy smoke
how you doing your skills would have come to
light him but Bobby's not getting it because
it's on Loop he'll figure it out sniper one
radio chip Bobby radio check he's going to
tell his Loop okay get your Sniper 2 radio
check Sniper 2 your gun okay now do it quick
or Purge Daddy Let's Go Leo come on now o he
knew oh there's been a breach all right grab
all the guns oh okay they have their silencers
on someone betrayed us what I can't trust anyone
put on that vest listen and do what purge daddy
says cuz Purge daddy knows someone's coming to
kill you you understand me move yes go what the
hell is that nice did she not know that that was
in our own house he must have had a built when he
did the oh I love that okay what the hell is that
that was some quick construction is what that was
where the hell is she Jesus Christ oh so the old
man wasn't on it so both of us were right I'm glad
he's balding yeah screw you oh oh yeah shake him
yeah he's looking more and more familiar there
we go purge Daddy's back baby I'm sorry Purge
Daddy I didn't recognize you with all all that
purging I don't know what the that
is okay actor get your FaceTime oh love
this guy he's a great actor um or Mark
may be outside repeat your mark may be
outside he's just such a bummer cuz he
looks like such a skin head you know
I know it's terrible like like he's
got to be villain in everything
yeah I see her oh oh God hurry
up in the face not in the face no no no in
the chest I think oh that's better though oh
what's this what's this what's going on whoa
Purge Daddy had a hidden bomb that was wild
that was awesome so like what circumstances
did he foresee except for that exact one that
he would need a bomb in that room in that room
yeah well that that computer was the old guys
right was their computer so maybe he was like
I don't know if I trust them that some kind
of H grown militia those are skilled Merks with a
lot of money behind them enough to get to someone
on our staff I'm guessing it's the minister
the minister the NFA though a lot of them I'm
getting too close God he had a vest on yeah
but I feel like in there anyway it's a lot of
blood Leo we should call someone dang it that's
how they get the ambulance yes that's how the
stories merge but more importantly that's how his
shirt comes off yes get your head in the game I'm
here Roxy you brought me back you were thinking
about how the plot is going was and not about
the most important thing we've been speaking
living the moment you know they're tracking us
I'm also not trying to be a [__] but they're
moving very slow yeah daddy feels a little off
his game oh God somebody shoot the Drone yeah
take take out the Drone that's a homemade drone
purgers now what run fast find the closest
store with wigs and be like Senator put this
on God you got to know your moments that
was a good one know your moments was good
satisfaction I feel if I got you at home you
must admit it you cannot lie be honest it's
your best quality oh it's got a skull attached
dang cuz that drone means business they putting
a lot of work on that drone 35 y back 15
y up snipe it yeah that was pretty good
skills on her part 35 yards back 15 yards
up yeah good for her what she military too
tooo that got me that got me good that got you
that got whoa he has an axe what the [__] I
was looking at the clown oh no no oh my godington
do something Senator she will she will yes she's
not usess she's not a dummy she's not useless
girl from the last one that we did not enjoy
ah behind you behind you they tased them oh
no this is no bueno they're crazies and we
know they're political yep because because
they're they're dressed as a politic as a
politic oh these are the people who
are here in this country these are
the people that we saw oh yes that
came here from the other country
to kill type of people yeah that's
why they're dressed as Americans cuz
they're did you say I brought an americ bazooka
I I think she said you're an American like sucker
Su okay this is the American yeah whoa who
no it's the guy from above the shop owner
yes Abraham Lincoln down Senator I knew they
saw her whoa love it come with us Goosebump
City Senator come with us oh yeah in his head
he's probably like what how the did you guys
get outside like why are you here stay she's
not bro stay stay I got to ask you cuz I'm
just a nosy old dog how did you get there what
is in Mississippi was you doing outside on Purge
Night senator Goodbye Blue Cheese you're a first
aid kid Leo my security was shot I'm fine you're
not fine I'm fine you're not sit Purge mom is
going to sew you up he told her stay she said
sit that's one up hold my beer sick you what's
your name where you from maros Mexico City but
I'm been an American citizen for 2 years you
got a record not here what's your name pal you
know what Mr Secret Service me you should be
thanking my black ass for helping you instead
of interrogating me his name is Joe Dixon Joe
Dixon I offended you truth to it the dumb light
of the cars are back shut up Poli that's when
the script was like insert loud dialogue for
tension yeah no reason to actually fight make
it up that's where they were going they they
went to Go Wrap another car with the lights get
their friends they need to call their their girl
you know talk about the medic girls they got
to call them oh yep they do you need help and
back she's really good yeah and I brought some
friends that actress's eyes are like I feel it
she gives Crazy Eyes good here come on girl pick
up I want to purse tonight I want to purse to God
lady what lady you want a purge what happens to
these people let him come Purge on these girls
outside yes release the beast on these [__]
outside we are going to purge today burn this
[__] down I didn't like the song there was
no Melody to it not catchy at all the lyrics
weren't that creative give you a gun but you're
not on the front line Over My Dead Body then
you better drop dead she right Senator then
you better drop dead I'm with Leo we need as
many guns as we can get all right girl she said
then you better drop dead my mom's not going to
like this this is what the parage is all about
me getting mine you getting yours and nobody
stopping anybody bye bye mother say good night
[__] because Here Comes Your candy girl their
extreme close-ups are so freaky yeah just the way
that they've shot them they are those actresses
are really good and they're doing an amazing job
making them like lowlevel menacing threats that
could really F [__] up yeah especially
that close they lingered on that pig mask
where I was like yeah it's not like the people
we've seen in the past that are like you know
really like government Associated could really
like have high power they're just like purging
kids man right oh here we go hit them hit them
run them over yes girl pedal to the metal baby
yes
yes oh my God that was so exciting I also kind
of feel bad but also but also like wait here
wait so what is it do you think that she did
that gave her this reputation oh man I don't
know but killed a lot of people oh she's not
looking around I love her yeah cuz she got a
call we need your help and she's like yeah [__]
oh there she is get it change my mind she's the
real purge mommy whoa shotgun to the face I
got your message lady oh no when they open up
for her oh no I'm scared well sh please don't
die somebody else is going to where we go the
van goh but I got a guy in there why are they
leaving now I don't I don't know oh CU of the
back door got it go now if you stay I stay just
leave yeah take them out why can't they all go
around back yeah just kill them maybe it's our
do to help protect her we'll rebuild the deli
she'll she'll rebuild the deli just leave it
dude just let them have all the candy hope they
are going to destroy it but she better fix
it this Senator better fix it where are we
headed underground treeh Center service in the
Community it's completely secure I feel so bad
for him right now that's like his life yeah why
I don't get why they couldn't have gone around
the other side they they couldn't yeah I'd be
like go run into them like [Music] yeah oh Jesus
Christ uh this is probably the first time she's
really seen Purge Knight up close other than
the time that her mom had to make that choice
right she un that's also her no I think she's
seeing it who the hell is this lady you big dope
you get people from the neighborhood a bad name
those shot sound far oh it's Crossfire not for
us but is for someone and you are Senator yeah
I hear it dang it oh my gosh from above how
are y'all going to survive that Jesus Christ
Rondo's dead oh he was the only one we could
lose it's such a plot wise such a shame fight
it's survival of the like you don't think of
under the freeway as the safe place right he's
the fittest of them all stop denying him he
definitely looks like it I mean we got one
shirtless crazy person I can't believe Rondo
died I know I kind of liked him popping in to
be like who are you guys and I kind of want him
to learn something and then maybe help Purge but
we just heard that he was a good kid did she
said Jesus Christ Rhonda's dead can we just
wait here no they'll have units on the ground
there was no way they could have known me be
in this van doesn't matter they did I'm using your
armrest I didn't know that till now use it up girl
thanks what is going on oh it's a Tracker yeah
that must be what it is got it smart oh ask
somebody else to do it also shouldn't the EMT be
like let me help you out real quick all right help
them get it out okay Bo there's a whole bunch of
negroes coming right this way and we sitting up
here like a bucket of mother maybe like have the
senator speak right like step out and be like I'll
help each one of you they'll start blasting if
we move they'll start blasting if we don't leave
triage alone what are you guys thinking about
what's the plan I know what I heard I know what
I heard I told you I ain't no saint everybody's
got a past veteran was a [__] whistle oh [__]
whistle I said veteran thing I know what I heard
he says yeah but also he said if this is the right
set we're not going to hurt you just help my boy
he's going to die we help you you do something for
us take this bullet yeah but then he's going
to die to the other side of the world wow he
was a [__] holy crap I have so many follow-up
questions then he changed his ways and opened up
a shop I said oh it must been Mill military thing
and they were like know no she he like nope he's a
GP oh did they put it in the water smart oh no
but why would they do that they needed to keep
it moving Earl we found the trace bullet but
no sign of the target I'd be like once those
people are there then shoot them yeah
yeah yeah good good good go take care of
them e oh we see it says white power on your
shirt around you to come in come in I need a
sitre you know who I don't care about getting
killed white power people yeah none of them ha
Rondo I'm still upset about yeah good kid so the
bullet go through his vest or just hit him in the
shoulder yeah good question I don't know maybe he
didn't have a vest on oh no he didn't have a vest
on cuz remember he took off his shirt he didn't
have yeah what are we you'll see what will we
see when I find out who she is I feel like she's
from yes that and right that shot of her walking
in there I was like was she in The Last of Us she
wasn't uh she seemed yeah Walking Dead call this
a safe Zone oh there he is there's our guy we have
doctors and nurses EMTs paramedics look these are
the real victims of The Purge the people that
the nffa are trying to eliminate that is sad of
tactics that you employ I am Purge night I can't
say that I agree with any of it I'll tell you what
you get elected you stop this night and I don't
have to do what I do anymore yeah he's basically
just the resistance yeah it's one thing in like in
concept to not agree with what he's doing but what
is he actually supposed to do it's kind of like
they have no choice they do have a choice yeah
I mean it's not a good one yeah it's not a great
one I I would do what he's doing and be like I'm
going to I think I would too kill off these these
people like when they went to that rich party and
the last one I was like heck yeah yeah I know
I know cuz we don't even know what his tactics
fully are is it like is it truly kill the rich
or be killed by the rich because then you have to
kill him right right or maybe he goes after like
because that rich party was almost white power too
right all everyone was white there I think this
it's kind of the same Vibe I don't think everybody
was white there really at the party yeah I the
rich party I REM old white lady and those old
it was a lot of white people yeah there was a lot
time to go got to get back to the de no are you
crazy we're safe here L you know I'll walk back if
I have to why I'll drive you I mean but if we run
into any problems we're coming right back here do
why though I get you want to protect just like Let
It Go like you can already yeah it's already like
they saw their way in I'm going to go take a look
around okay stay here yes Purge Daddy okay boss
oh see she said it she's the vibe did I ask you
did you watch l yeah I did watch it I love lost
you know her that I just can't remember anything
Roxy apparently the only person that I really
Tru she's the doctor is the bald guy she's the
uh Island when they find her later with Benjamin
lius yeah the only yes now I'm remembering she
with Sawyer but then with Jack with the Sawyer
yes then she with Jack and and it's Jack Jack
but then Sawyer kind of I'm not doing a great
job describing it she was doing the fertility
stuff her and Kate had beef and then they were
cool and they had beef some of is about soer
Jack
perge maybe it's cuz you don't have
the perch pillow I don't have it
Fortress what's he doing it's almost out of focus
which is interesting why is he like sneaky music
what are you doing here hand why are you here
maybe don't cause issues I mean he said hand he
warned y'all everybody's okay back up we okay all
right all right what's going on I'm just getting
my weapon just doing my job wait but you didn't
do your job yet you didn't look we didn't find out
anything yet those are The Minister's biggest
Financial supporters they have assassination
plans for them you're going to assassinate him
yeah there we go you got there it just took one
minute you're going to assassinate the minister
tonight aren't you that's too much Exposition for
me I think she should have only said it once yeah
and quicker yeah just like get to it I need to
win this thing fair and they are not playing fair
and square and neither should we believe in me we
that's why we're trying to pave away from you she
says there's trucks approaching us oh this is how
they're not playing fair and square there we go
Lany I need you with third and tox now yeah we'll
meet you there oh man there's going to be a hiccup
I feel it good thing that uh Joe was insistent to
go back to his shop so that right this movie
is sepia I hate this night and boom they're
going to get a blow up or something oh what they
some they're going to hit a bomb or something I
feel something weird G to happen to them they're
they're going to hit a bomb there's a bomb in the
road Fortress for the first time Fortress I did it
Fortress you said bomb so I thought I learned oh
no oh that's some saw [__] right
there kidding me well y all Can duct yeah
duck it why didn't you guys just crawl yeah
then they said good luck out there they're like
we're not really trying to kill you we're just
making an obstacle if you make enjoy that's a
huge setup for just a little bit of fun but hey
you guys is okay yeah thank you music's creepy
someone's up where we headed drive out of this
city get us out of here where are we headed
Drive hopeful no she's going to make him go
save him I know it she's going to the church
yeah right like for sure she can't know about
an assassination attack and then not and then not
I have to stop them from killing the minister if
they assassinate him he becomes a martyr and
how do we do that I don't know we have to do
something you willn't risk your life to to
save an assassin yes see I said bomb but it
was just a big truck who hit her these just
random Purge people right or is it like the
stupid white power people in a tanker you would
be so discombobulated oh yeah oh God that was a
quick snatch and scary what happened she said
they snatched her who I don't know oh my God
you guys what and it's in an armored okay well
he should have aimed for the tires what I know
where they're taking her I know why she's still
alive Purge Daddy's got work to do do you know
Pur mom going to help no I know where they're
taking her and I know why she's still alive
maybe to the CH [Music] no these are the white
power people yeah but where are they taking her
exactly oh they're probably taking her actually to
the church cuz they're on the bad side to the to
the other guy right maybe or other guy's going
to killer well he's playing he's playing dirty
too so maybe yeah maybe the minister was like
killer or yeah but then why haven't they killed
her why do they have to keep her
alive yeah it's a church he's probably going to
be like step down and say it on camera I have so
many ideas resign or die yeah there the people are
going to come save her yeah they're going to get
there to kill him but they're going to see her La
Resistance what is [Applause] this okay are they
going to are they going to put her up on a and
cross and nail her to the Cross like a why do you
think that's what they're going to do I don't know
I don't know I just think like what's the most up
thing wait why is she passed out why is she
why is she in a yeah let's go find a place to
wait out the rest of this so they're just guns
for hire she was so worried he was going to be
a martyr and she keeps saying I have I'm willing
to die for it she might not make it through this
movie she might not maybe maybe if if she does
die then everyone's like no and then that side
has to win right like who she who's this person
who is that that looked like the guy that was her
security at her place that gave her up but
I don't think it is though well it's been a
long journey to get away from the lies and the
self deception to this place of knowledge and
awareness of who we really are pieces of [__]
yeah this is like you say people of Flesh we
see people of [__] to get rid of the fury and
the hatred that poisons our souls makes us sick
makes us ugly I'm not trying to make people hate
me but has religion ever helped anything let's
have a whole conversation about that yeah it's
so complicated Purge and purify say it with me
how is that practicing What You Preach right and
they're like get rid of all the hatred and the
and the pain and I'm like but that's exactly what
you you exist for that mid need to move I need is
this I cannot wait got it got it get it got it
good for right yeah tell them what happened you
know this lunatic Dante yeah he's Purge daddy
remember they knew each other from last movie
from before yeah trying to get yourself killed
is that the tunnel for the cathedral how the you
know about the tunnel speak quicker man yeah tell
him why are you ignoring him just tell him that
you tell him she's in there this is no longer an
assassination it's a rescue it's a rescue mission
and then the music comes in and now our modern
day martyr will die for our trespasses which one
is that guy maybe it's her VP yeah like Lawrence
oh a lifelong drug addict he wants to make amends
he wants to serve his God and His government
a poor lawen let's thank Lawrence for his
gift oh my gosh you guys are the worst
God terrible Karen Karen one Karen two
thank you Lauren Harmon will be the first
purger of the evening oh God he looks like
a pure psychopath we're not even going
to be able to save him he's about to
get [Music] Rondo what he going to do like
carve his heart out what your soul let the
light in you are oh my god do you think she's
feeling so bad for him right now or do you
think she's scared about herself or bothar
probably both his light entered your heart
Haron oh God they both just come I'm so grossed
out right now he does look like a vampire he
like red around his eyes and crackly white
lips like G what is going on you ever heard
of BTS bees buddy no matter what happens
we stay together move quicker like there's
no urgency it's like we don't really need
to stop to talk we just need to like move
and yeah I do understand it is a movie yeah
I just wish there were more walking talks you
know this person has threatened to dismantle
everything it's going to be such a theatrical
reveal when he pulls the cap off and yet she
tried to save his life how do you think the
audience is going to react they're probably
going to clap and get excited cuz they're
Psychopaths yeah I know they're they're so
handshakes oh my God I hate them all I would
like all the founding fathers to come to the
altar as we eliminate evil and Purge as one
oh God the founding fathers of of what the
new country founding fathers Association oh
what yeah nice shank all they're getting
out with the old in with the new and the
new is like white power bring it back cuz
they suck bless it be our new fing fathers
for letting us Purge go faster shank shank
them Purge Daddy come on shank Purge daddy
in the shank yeah oh it's going to be noise
Nation reborn all right come on snipe yeah
snipe it oh my God you've got it kid oh
oh my God bye-bye old man oh such a sweet
shot how does she not die throughout all
this though right like and how does she
not get shot yeah right like the vampire
dude standing up get him right like what
is he what is he doing come on y'all oh
he's going to walk away maybe he's going
to find chapstick she's alive after all that
that's surprising but hey oh great here we
go you would think they would
feel like sacred about the
church the hell are yall doing up there oh
nice bring your ass is down here where y'all
at oh man I wanted to see him do it but that
was a cool reveal they were so stoked like I
was thank you got got she said thank you yeah
but what about Vamp like come on she's got to
have one one or two bullets somewhere in the
arm or the leg or something that was a full-on
bullet Fest what was that take care business
Go cover we're headed out back exit we have
her what who's him the guy that came to kill the
minister oh yeah he got it got it got it got it
yes the minister the minister yeah I thought
it was one of the bad guys on the radio being
like this is murder if you do this you will
be no different than them out of my way D's
on a mission man we can't be like them is
that the minister yeah yeah it looks like
him you're right as an American oh no he's not
going to kill you yeah that when you're saying
that just shoot him in the knee and
get out of there he's going to whack
him in the head knock him out come on and
what about vampire where's the vampire
yeah where did he go oh hello Minister
did the right thing we believed in you
where is the vampire yeah there's something
up there is he hiding in here I am going to
beat the [__] out of you on Election Day
Is that the name of the movie election day
right Purge election day it's election year
or election day don't know election day good
night blue cheese good night blue cheese this
isn't election day though you mean it's not
this day is not election day right right I
feel like it was year oh cut oh no no no no
yeah I mean the resistance can't can't win it
the whole time did our guy didn't die right no
oh he's still it's bad okay it was close to
the but not the he said I have one more move
in me what is it oh he's going to just pedal the
metal the car whenever somebody in these movies
says cover me it's kind of like I wouldn't
know what that meant like just d d du wire a
car all right yep do it let's get
it roll out of there oh he wasn't
even going to get out oh he got killed oh he
got killed sacrifice what a big sacrifice it
was oh Purge daddy out of ammo yeah oh what she
doing oh W yeah use the glass
from the window and cut him
yeah one of you is fighting for money and the
other you is fighting for the right thing to
do and the right thing to do always wins yeah
you shanked it pretty good just then that was
awesome Terra and Roxy are watching The Purge
it's getting very bloody it's giv me the urge
to close my eyes but I won't do that cuz she
does doesn't want to purge no I supposed to
rhyme bro that was good no you said you said
urge and then I did The Purge I started with
Purge then went to urge then I went to that
and then it was like something about a hat
yeah I brought it back in all the wrong
ways oh okay nice come on finish him off
make sure he's dead no he's learned from
the senator that makes you know better than
them no don't do that buddy buddy oh there he goes
there is aamp there he is oh oh no oh no not the
sniper no no I'm so sad I liked him he's out what
of ammo oh my God no he's how come on guys good
good good good good yeah come on now oh no oh no
they're going to die no Joe I guess it doesn't
matter that your shop little sh is messed up those
dumb [__] it's the two of them no no she's going
to take over his shop the final scene is going
to be them making his shop into some great
place for people we got to get you somewhere
okay you going to be okay I don't think he
Isles oh good I thought he Oh I thought he
was dead oh he's going to give him the shot
yep May 26 two months later but the purge is on
the March 21st so it's two months and a couple
days yo to be honest get it straight election
day yes cuz all of our elections are on May
26th I am getting word right now Florida that
the senator has also taken Florida that's what
he said she need to do yes it is now official
the next president of the United States will
be Charlie Ron that her first order of business
you're right it's going to be them two at the
shop updates it's a landslide all right I'll
come by tomorrow we can get started on the
ceiling no I know her well from something what
is it I think by the end of the movie I think
it's Michael with an a y or something I can't
I'm just picturing this place is really coming
along Marcos Joe would be really happy Joe would
be yeah and I now live my life to make Joe happy
nffa supporters are reacting violently to this
defeat they are burning cars BR Windows loting
attacking police officers oh okay setting us up
for that huh James demonico and of course it's
Jason Plum Plum House for the win and I always
forget that Michael Bay produces this let me see
these credits baby music game strong throughout
we even had a Miley Cyrus song okay Todd Miller
editing Whitehead that's a tough laugh last
name Frank gillow Frank Elizabeth Mitchell okay
that's the girl from Lost M Michael T Williams
and I said Michael Williams Oh my God I almost
got there I was like I think it's Michael the
Y and Williamson Michael T Williamson so close
yet had so far I was I was quite far I was close
and far yeah oh but what was what was she in we'll
look it up in a little um big thanks to expressvpn
for sponsoring this video a real game changer
I've been using for years that's right years
so whenever they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about expressvpn
for online privacy and security but there's
more to it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum showing down
my internet and contacted me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I realized I
hadn't actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months ago so I
was paying the consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years go that
made expressvpn my go-to for both security and
freedom I mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on Netflix
that are not available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your fingertips
it's super easy open expressvpn switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kdramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so
if you want to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you can get
an extra 3 months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to expressvpn.com
reex to learn more thank you again all right so
word that'd be good that was good I was in it uh
it as in it as in one and two no so like you were
saying some of the pacing it it did slow down a
little bit like uh I'm looking not not as much as
one or two there was just more I don't know maybe
it's cuz we were closer it seemed maybe quicker
maybe the state seemed higher cuz we were in the
actual environment in two and then in one we were
just in that little house um and in this one it
seemed like the problems were solved quickly
right like I mean I don't know I don't know
how to explain it I still really liked this one
but I wasn't as on the edge of my seat as I was
in like one and parts of two this one's a little
difficult because it makes you like at the end of
the day I might kill the the homeboy what's his
name the guy that the minister Minister oh yeah
yeah yeah Minister I might because go f yourself
yeah totally and you just tried to kill me but
like you want the people in charge to be better
than you right you don't want you to be in charge
you want the people at the top to be the example
of good yeah yeah so I like this Senator is it
realistic I mean we've never had somebody as good
run for president ever that is that pure as she is
like and also does it really solve the problems
like we heard throughout like a a lot of the
people in this movie and rightfully so like the
main woman helping per are the actual Purge mommy
who's like yo my people get left behind no matter
what yeah yeah I don't know it's interesting cu
the first movie like we talked about is very
isolated yeah second movie we go out into the
world third movie we break the rules and we find
out that actually now you can go for elected
officials anybody anybody that's supposed to even
the playing field and it's almost like by opening
up those stakes and giving us the whole world the
stakes did feel a little a little less right which
is kind of weird it was still really solid and I
don't know what I could have wanted from a third
one that they didn't deliver and I'm glad we had
Frank gillow carry through because we needed like
some yeah some something we needed that action
and that like knowledge or like the the maybe
it's just the Nostalgia no it's like it's like
his like Purge dadness but also his knowledge led
us to automatically associate that like he could
save the senator if they were as long as they were
together right that like it started out really
interesting with the heist at the house right
like with them coming together her and turning
on her but I do also feel like we didn't fully
come full circle with that like why did they turn
on her the PE her own defense you know I mean you
can assume for money because they're working with
the minister you know you can assume but I wanted
to hear was there another side to why we didn't
like this politician you know she seems like so
good but maybe they turned on her because maybe
she screwed their families or something you know
like maybe there was something more to the
story and I feel like that would have made
it a little more well-rounded even though it was
entertaining as hell like I kind of am nitpicking
because honestly this whole franchise is pretty
dope is great but I agree with you because uh in
I mean they said like you're not getting paid if
she's not if she's dead or whatever they said but
I thought that when that's why I thought when she
was in the ambulance looking out the window and
you're like no that's just her point of view
I thought it was a flashback to her childhood
with these people hanging from the trees and I
thought that maybe that was her as a little girl
dancing and I was like are we going to go back
to that to where it's like she was bad at one
point and if any body finds out or if they did
find out that's why they're like seller but we
didn't that wasn't that she was just I guess
looking at the Carnage we also never do come
back to her mom picking to save her life and like
what that does for a person you know she never I
kind of wanted maybe that's why is there another
one after this yeah yeah I think so but I don't
know like do you think they're just saving all
of that it's possible but I I wanted what I a
moment that I wanted was this is a politician I
want to see her stand up and give a big speech
right like you know I this is what happened to
me as a kid I've been personally affected by this
I have survivors remorse everybody here does we
collectively have have experienced a trauma like
some kind of rounded out thing you know yeah I
mean that would have been great to see also it
would have been cool if they if they had a little
more yeah backstory as to why they would turn on
her cuz she seems like a good like a good person
right um and I'm like how much money really are
you getting but then I like ah okay fine maybe
that's the purpose of this whole universe though
that like a l is everything yeah that's true I
mean we've learned that in both of the movies
it's not like they're going to change the plan
now that these people are out to to make more
money and kill you know the people that they feel
are lesser than this one also felt the longest
did it feel that way to you I don't know if it
was pacing right the pacing they they there was
a lot of instead of walking talk instead of sork
and walk and talk they did a lot of stop and talk
stop and talking stop and talk stop and talk and
lives are in danger and as I you know it's not a
real search and rescue mission however if it was
pick up the pace baby yeah and that has to be a
direction move because if we if we just imagine
him when you know when he reveals himself in the
tunnel and they're like who's that guy that I
imagine sure he could say it for a second but
then he's like I guess it would be bad if he was
running but I still feel like hey it's me I need
to tell you like this isn't a blah blah blah it's
now a rescue mission where's the tunnel we got to
move like and then they're like moving and talking
they have her they have her we got switch yeah
yeah yeah something to really get it to where you
know in movies where they're like they're on that
mission and the the music kicks in and now we're
like really moving I thought that was like maybe
going to happen and it still took its time yeah
it was dragging a little bit I'm super with you
on this I want to see if this was a different
director so this one was James demonico okay
and let's see no he did he did too and two and one
wow interesting so he did he did The Purge series
he did The Purge forever he did the What's called
the F the first Purge which I guess is The Purge
after Purge election year he did The Purge UK he
did The Purge Anarchy and he did The Purge but he
wrote The Purge did he not direct it let's see um
CU like the first one is The Purge that we watch
yeah no he directed it he directed and directed
it okay it did feel different it really did I'm
I'm with you but it it felt slowed down and it
yeah it felt like maybe they wanted it to breathe
more but in it breathing more I had more questions
than I had answers I got to also figure out where
that woman Betty is from okay she was in upgrade
which was a movie that I love oh dude you know who
she is the second I opened it I realized who she
is she's the single here get out girl oh my God
that must be her right okay the second I opened
this up I was like wait I'm looking at a picture
of her yes oh yeah she she work that's why she's
so good I mean she is so good the actors in This
franchise are so good seriously Beyond yeah I age
really really like Beyond excellent I don't have
an issue with a single performance in this whole
franchise no not at all and I do agree in what
you said at the top this movie and none of these
movies would work this well if the casting wasn't
entirely on point meaning with the direction and
the producing coming together going we need that
person specifically because and and the chemistry
has always been topnotch like I've never believed
if they've set two characters up that they didn't
already have a relationship yeah but it is wild
that like we are watching an entire Purge and my
brain is thinking make out make out make out like
why does Frank Gilla would have chemistry with
a a brick wall yeah he would he would we got I
mean they they did light up that peack a little
bit man it had like a red light on it you guys
can stop go rewind it was good looking I think
another again this is being so nitpicky and I
don't mean to because I actually did really like
this movie while I was watching it but because
there was that time to breathe another thing that
just bothers me about Society sometimes is that
I do think that each life is equal every life
is equal everybody's time matters equally and
we did do everything on the planet to protect the
senator and in in protecting the senator we killed
the only guy that was in all three of these movies
like because she wanted to stay home she was so
insistent on staying home and not being where it
was the safest place for her yeah which I get I
understand because she wants to be a citizen
and live like a citizen but at the same time
every single person died around her including
Joe including um the like the one that I just
mentioned the kid the kid the good kid Rondo died
and and people were shot it's and including the
leader of the resistance and so many members of
the resistance and it's just like I can I can we
really justify for saving the I get it's for the
greater good and she is about to be the leader of
the greater good and she's going to take down
the minister and she is the best chance at the
future and the best chance at ending The Purge
but at the same time am sitting here like and
and she did fight to keep people alive you know
she did try to keep the minister alive and she
did try to um say them we're no better than them
but also we were all protecting her even Joe at
the end jumps in front of the bullet for her and
it's like does her life matter more than anybody
else's I understand that's what it's like to be a
bodyguard and what it is to protect the government
officials but I don't know it just kind of irks me
a little yeah I mean the one thing that might have
that might kind of save it is that Joe at the end
he's like well the senator will take care of it
won't you senator like basically he knew that it
was for the larger picture which does make us feel
a little bit better about it but I do agree with
you that a lot of people had to die for her um
but I guess the the the ideal is that just the the
greater picture will succeed of like goodness over
these like white powered freaks who still want
the purge she's the only one well not the only
one but the only one that we saw that was against
The Purge in trying to like change the world and
she has all of these people who are on her side
and then just the total opposite that's and I'm
glad that you won but I'm curious to see the setup
that they left us with yeah me too that's that's
just seems like another Insurrection like ready
and waiting maybe it is maybe it it is actually
a good thing that it is making me ask myself these
questions you know like what does matter most and
and is the greater good a good enough reason to do
something and you know I think that that all these
movies have made me think genuinely and I know
it's supposed to be kind of like a silly franchise
a horror franchise but to me they gen the thought
and and even the fact that the my first instinct
when we're seeing the purge and crime rate go
down and I'm just like huh it's an interesting
concept and it's like no dude this is a way to eat
the poor [__] yet again like and for the rich
to keep [__] pushing down people that will NE
you know for the 1% and it's like every movie has
really made me deep in thought about something
this one's no different and I really I'm sure
people are like you're overthinking it but to
me they are thought-provoking yeah they are for
sure I mean I think there were some similarities
in this like what when I was comparing the rich
white people party to like the rich white people
Minister people it seemed like very similar like
the resistance is now going to come in and has to
take these people down because that's what they
do and and you know Senator was saying before I
don't really agree with your methods but at the
end of the day they really are making this purge
way just way worse they really are taking out all
of the the weak people which is why now the they
have to have a safe Zone to bring in like homeless
people and people that are like tracked after
which is so sad and now we've I guess in this
movie it's a culmination of how bad the purge has
become and how much the people of the world have
to now sacrifice their life to save the people in
their Hood and the people that they still want to
be around so that they don't don't just end up
with like a bunch of white power people coming
into their shop wait like coming in to buy a
Snickers and be like can't wait for the purge
next year it's going to take you down like you
know it it is like a very no matter which way
you think about it these like you said it it is
very thought-provoking it does make you think and
there's so many ways to to like move with these
story lines but them delivering it each and every
time does make you think like how do these people
get out of this how how do they get out of it when
we see what the president does and we'll see what
she's able to do see what's up I mean I'd give
this like a seven seven out of 10 because of the
pacing but I think the last purchese I was like
eight out of 10 I I still I love this I love the
franchise me too and I love frank Gill's character
because heal way not we got and Sh Minister but he
does do the right thing and like he's interesting
he's complex man and I I think he's a good lead
for the franchise I hope that he's in the fourth
one I hope we get to see it which is up to you
guys like comment subscribe let us know hopefully
you are enjoying the series as much as we are
where could they go from here yeah I mean I'm
I'm gonna be interested to see the senator and
that relationship carry out with Frank gilla's
character if we get to I mean I would I would hope
one what did I but then I'm like what's the what's
the uh I don't know what the next one is but
I'm like what's the what's the Resurrect The
the resistance look like because we now we don't
have our leader it's like going to be a whole new
ball game right The Purge forever is uh written
by the same person but directed by somebody else
and completely different no knew none of the
same people oh okay so totally different so we
don't maybe we don't get a call back to that but
I don't wait no the first Purge is next after the
purge election year comes the first Purge which
it probably throws us back to the first Purge
okay which a lot of people I'm into that all right
we got Mera to is in this one we got I'm not gonna
look Greg I'm not looking I'm not looking I'm not
looking I won't remember said Marissa to out loud
and I'm not going to forget that I will no mer
to is not forgettable we got to get out of here
before I blow we got to go we got to go we love
you guys thanks comment tell us how cool we are
because we love you so much and most importantly
remember to vote later rejects [Music] bye